Rob here with a GS news update the beta  for destiny will be launching next week  on the Xbox one and it won't be in 1080p  although it was revealed by Bungie that  the xbox one won't be running the beta  in 1080p they want to emphasize that  this is a true beta experience and not a  peek at the finished game Bungie still  intends for the Xbox one to run the  final game in 1080p Bungie community  manager deej said we are aiming for  1080p on all platforms the game was  originally planned to run below 1080p on  the Xbox one but due to system  optimizations by Microsoft likely  stemming from the removal of a mandatory  connect bungee is now planning to bump  the resolution the destiny beta kicks  off today for ps3 and PlayStation 4 but  doesn't arrive on Xbox one until july  23rd the beta will run until July 27  make sure you tune in to gamespot com  where we will be streaming our  experiences in the beta and sharing  guides for all the different classes  thanks for watching